hallo wir machen heute eine reise ins
mittelalter holen sind wir heute klaus
wir sind auf der burg satzvey in der
schönheit
was gibt der zwergstaat ihn ein mit
alter markt ein ritterfest und wer hat
uns hierhin eingeladen
peter und wo sbb spitals in der uni ja
okay wir schauen uns jetzt trotzdem wir
und guck mal was so gibt los geht's was
sind das für menschen die sich zu
verkleiden
fragt jedoch einfach mal gehirn und
fahre ich doch ganz nett
ich habe ja mittelalter studiert ja eben
da hatte ich auch solche die sind dann
barfuß dem schwert im winter zur uni
gekommen oder als martin martin
gastinger chips gegönnt
ein honig bier an das mittelalter
gezwungen mehr aber kommt ihr auf der
ecke und ich kann es noch nicht und was
machen wir hier genau
naja ich bin waffenhändler und verkaufe
waffen waffenhändler was haben sie denn
hier so anzubieten deutsche schwert holz
blank waffen
wir würden gerne mal fragen was sich
eine gewänder tragen was wir für
gewänder tragen als sind gewänder die
damals zur zeit der kreuzzüge getragen
worden sind sind recherchiert und
entsprechend nachbearbeitet wurden eines
alltags gewonnen hat nachdem sie denn
hier
ich versuche ein kettenhemd zu
reparieren das so im laufe der zeit
einfach dinge verloren hat und
dementsprechend große löcher da hat wo
sie nicht hingehören würden wir uns das
noch mal erklären das sprichwort einen
zahn zulegen
also dieses thailand in der topf hängt
wenn sich sega einen zahn zulegen heißt
das ganze heißer machen indem man einen
zu haben
das ganze ein fahren weiter nach unten
hängt
oder zwei oder mehr zähne je nachdem
irgendwann ist natürlich ende aber kommt
sprich wurde ein zahn zulegen
das beta jetzt am pranger
was ist los was hast du verbrochen
pieper ich will gar nicht darüber reden
was willst du hast du mir geklaut dann
nehme ich bitte losmachen du ich weiß ja
es geht diese mit ihr machen sie sich
denn hier gerade bereit
wir machen wird bereit wir gleich mit
allen lagern zusammen einlaufen vorne in
der grossen arena
ok ja und dann sammeln sich die lager
vorher
und dann sieht man unseren großen zug
durch diese renault wird vorgestellt und
volk jubelt und das volk jubelt da sind
wir auch gleich bei welches lager
vertreten sie denn wir sind die frauen
löwen zu boden
wie benimmt sich denn der fehler bei
denen aus dem gewahrsam gekommen ist
werbefrei mit der ganzen welt die ganze
wissen warum wir haben ja so ne also
wenn wir so eine tradition dass wir uns
immer alle drei monate hat jemand von
uns eine idee was wir zusammen
unternehmen
deine idee war dass wir zu dieser burg
erfahren und wir sind denn alle wegen
diesen gefahren hätte es auch mal wieder
drauf gekommen
ich schlage vor dass wir gleich war
gleich fängt ja nicht so an
und dann sehen wir auch so ein paar
ritterkämpfen auf werden und auch so fuß
ich glaube dass ganz actionreiche
geschichte die unsere zuschauer brennend
interessiert
[Musik]
das welcher epoche stammt er denn
außerdem wird man zeuge seiten des
jahrhundert und stähler 2 ritter die
schlacht von worringen dann könnte uns
das ganz kurz erzählen was ist da
passiert
der berichtszeitraum limburg war einer
der größten deutschen entlasten im
mittelalter und es ging um den sieg von
westerburg die damaligen erzbischof von
köln
der wollte stadthalle gesicht haben und
da hat der herr von brabant gesagt
nehmen geht nicht und dann gab es eine
kleine schlacht ja jetzt ganz instanzen
willen zum beispiel gerade die beiden
haben sich etwas wochen geschnappt und
wir werden jetzt schon bemerken der
kampf ist ganz anders
er gibt es bisschen mehr zur sache darum
ist es auch ein bisschen mehr
ist ja auch klar wenn ich uns stößt das
verlängert mein leben ich habe mir schon
dann kann man einfach viel mehr machen
und die beiden sind auch schon lange
dabei auch weiter gut geschützt der
einer zum beispiel wie man ganz gut
gitter vor den augen gehabt hätte an
allerdings hat auch noch hier oben
bisschen mehr schutz ohne helm
deswegen können sie jetzt ein bisschen
sich austoben dann wurden diese drängen
denn wirklich benutzt und wo im 12 13
jahrhundert werden und zwar auf dem
marktplatz durch vorstellung dass jeder
sehen konnte
hier ist halt etwas geschehen diebstahl
oder sonstiges und meistens dürfen die
leute dann noch mit faulem obst beworfen
werden
das hier zum beispiel ist eine gnade
gott das ist eine waffe die wurde
benutzt
um dem ritter den letzten gnadenstoß zu
geben
die ging auch durch ein panzer busch
anrühren solche ketten händen getragen
quer durchs ganze mittelalter im prinzip
ja in erster linie erstmal von gütern
dann später von soldaten wie schwer es
sein kennt nimmt ab 15 kilo auf vor was
hat einen das geschützt und vor was
nicht schnitte und streift schläge also
es ist eigentlich eine reine zweikampf
rüstung gegenteil beschuss hilft ein
kettenhemd gar nicht ich weiß von anfang
an standards werden weil du hast gesagt
wir treffen uns hier und du hast sicher
dass uns angelogen las und gleich
getroffen
das wird's gefallen ich glaube es war
auch klaus wirklich ein paar hersteller
wo ist kein thema das zu welchen man der
irgendwie näher mit vater und seine
augen verdeckt das kann gut sein dann
ist klaus der übeltäter überhaupt
klauser durch anfragen schnell der ist
abgehauen ist nadine erwischen und als
rächer zeit stammen sie denn
august nur darstellung aus dem dritten
jahrhundert ca 1280 und wann und
umgebung blieben sehr gut und was trägt
man jetzt so es ist ein kampf oder ist
das einfach alltagstauglich ist ein
bisschen was von beidem
man sieht ja schon die kette das
kettenhemd chefs gerade mainz ist hier
das gibt so ist dann haben wir noch die
rüstungsteile häufig ein helm zu helm
und schulterpolster brustpanzer und wenn
man dann alles an hat 25 30 kilo extra
im gepäck jetzt wäre gerne gewusst wir
sind hier auf dem offenbar auf einem
mittelaltermarkt auf einem ritterturnier
alle haben sich verkleidet nur wenige
aus den letzten betten
okay sie wird wieder raus h wird um
gnade bitten
ich bitte um gerade die herren wir
hätten gern ein liedchen ein mädchen das
während martin wilfing damit sie
freikommen
in der rückschau und die wände
tauchcenter shuttle-bus gibt einen koran
verbieten zum enthält und sie in die
welt des mittelalters
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jemand will mehr als nur eine chance
[Musik]
er liebe leute berta anderen folgen von
der burg satzvey petacchi war ein erstes
situation ihr super gut
was denkst du ich fand auch wieder
spannend her und martin bist du jetzt
ein mittelalter fans das war gänsehaut
pur ein kampf auf leben und tod
abliefert
weil es ihr auch mal lust immer noch
deutschland kommt um wollte man ein
richtiges mittelalters
dann kann schon mal hier vorbei unter
burg satzvey de findet ihr alle infos
und es gibt hier ganz auf solche sachen
also ritterturniere und ganz besonderen
echte schauspieler sondern mal vorbei
geht es an und wenn ihr noch vokabeln
lernen möchte dann schaut mal hier
vorbei wie ihr könnt ihr einfach schön
werden und noch über hofer und hier auf
jeder für sich
zum zweiten weil dir für deine bilder
wie diese tolle idee
[Musik]